how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel
and mcu and one division is now less
than two
weeks away 13 days to be exact before
one division premieres on disney plus
and as we've seen from the trailers and
tv spots things are going to get pretty
crazy
we obviously know at this point that
some of the show is going to be like a
sitcom
like many different old sitcoms but
eventually wanda is going to be
the true scarlet witch developing new
powers that we've never seen before
on screen in the marvel cinematic
universe and she'll kind of evolve from
wanda to the scarlet witch
and today we have a little bit more
insight on what her powers are going to
be
and what her official scarlet witch
costume is going to look like
so we'll break it all down in this video
but if you're new be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest mcu and
wanda vision news so to start it all off
wanda is going to become the scarlet
witch in the one division series
of course we've known her since avengers
age of ultron as the scarlet witch but
nobody has ever referenced her by that
name
in the mcu she's one of the strongest
marvel characters ever created not only
in the mcu but also in the comics
however we've only seen a fraction of
her true power
in the films and thanks to a combination
of a recent interview and some things
that kevin feige and elizabeth olsen
have told us themselves we have an idea
of what her new powers are going to be
and we have a look at her new outfit so
marvel studios over the past
month or so has been releasing new
posters of one division
and in the tvs that we see they make up
different parts of
wanda some of the pictures on the tv
show different parts of wanda from
different eras but now that we seemingly
have all the pictures we can combine
them and take a look at what wanda
scarlet witch costume the new one is
going to look like
and as you can see here it's quite the
upgrade from the old one
it's very very slick and it looks to be
like it's kind of
one piece not a bunch of different
layers thrown on to try and make her
look comic accurate
it actually looks pretty slick and kind
of stealth-like
overall i definitely think that it's a
huge upgrade and she's going to need it
since she's going to become
the scarlet witch now in a recent
interview with tv guide magazine
elizabeth olsen spoke up a little bit
about some episodes
and she talked about how the audience is
finally going to see wanda use some
abilities that we've never seen her use
in the movies but have seen her used in
the comics when talking about the magic
show that they put on for their little
town of westview she says
she's a magician's assistant helping
vision but doing all the tricks for him
and not letting the audience know it's
very funny and gaggy
she says the audience will finally see
abilities from wanda previously only
seen in the comics
hinting that these abilities have to do
with how and why
wand and vision progress to a different
decade for a reason
now there's ton of speculation that
could be had here but they're most
likely talking about wanda's
actual power of reality manipulation and
chaos magic
now we've kind of seen her chaos magic a
little bit in the mcu but we haven't
seen the reality manipulation yet that
is until the trailer for one division
and the tv spots that we have
they've shown her bending reality quite
frequently actually
and elizabeth olsen and kevin feige have
pretty much all but confirmed that
this show is going to be heavily based
off of the house of m
comic book line that's where wanda
alters reality and creates a world
that is ruled by mutants and not humans
now we probably won't get that exact
storyline but
what we're seemingly going to get is
reality manipulation
wanda further developing these abilities
until eventually they might get out of
control and that could be what leads up
to doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness
wanda changing and creating all of these
different realities
that combined with her chaos magic it's
going to be pretty hard to stop her if
she does indeed
kind of explode but we know that's going
to happen we know she's going to develop
her powers as the scarlet witch
meaning more chaos magic and reality
warping magic and actual magic
not just powers given to her from the
stone but actual
witchcraft if she wasn't already the
strongest character in the mcu
she is about to be and i can't wait to
see her reality warping and chaos magic
abilities
when this tv series comes in less than
two weeks so be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest one
division news don't forget to like the
video and comment below how excited you
are for the wanna vision series for live
updates you can follow me on twitter and
instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
me